sustainability and Health Care have
never necessarily been subjects that
people interfly but covet has taught us
and I think everybody sees the masks and
the rubber gloves and the tremendous
amount of medical waste that covet is
creating
um and I think it reveals to the larger
population with those of us in
healthcare have known for a long time
which is Healthcare is very wasteful it
creates a lot of medical waste but it's
also inefficient and expensive so we
focus on medical devices that can be
reused and repurposed longer welcome to
20-minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're talking about medical device
reprocessing and we're going to be
diving into that in just a second meet
Daniel vocalic the president and CEO of
the association of medical device
reprocessors amdr represents the
interests of member companies that
pre-process single-use medical devices
in accordance with federal law for use
at hospitals acute surgical Care Centers
and Physicians offices the industry has
doubled in size yearly on average for 20
years all under Dan's leadership in 2020
the reprocessing industry saved
providers over 440 million dollars in
device acquisition costs and an
additional three and a half million
dollars in a waste disposal cost savings
amdr's members provide reprocessed
devices to over 10 000 hospitals then
receive the Bachelor's of arts and a law
degree from the American University he
is a native of the Minneapolis and a
member of the Florida and District of
Columbia bars
foreign
really excited to understand your whole
world of medical device reprocessors you
are the president and CEO of the
association of medical device
reprocessors and so I'm looking forward
to learning all about amdr all about
your own career all about your journey
from getting your Bachelor of Arts and
law degree from American University to a
your you know passion for debate from
prior and all the way to what you're
doing today and so I'm a lot to uncover
in these 20 minutes and I'm already
excited for it so Dan thank you again
for being here what is medical device
reprocessing yeah you know I attend a
lot of conferences and I actually attend
uh conferences for Association
Executives and so all various trade
associations come together and when I
tell them I represent the association of
medical device reprocessors they say boy
there's really a meeting for everyone
isn't there an association for everyone
but I represent the companies that
commercially collect clean disinfect
repair or replace package sterilization
send back medical devices and to speak
to some of the issues that you brought
up at the beginning of the conversation
here I think sustainability and Health
Care have never necessarily been
subjects that people intertwine but
kovit has taught us and I think
everybody sees the masks and the rubber
gloves and the tremendous amount of
medical waste that covet has created and
I think it reveals to the larger
population with those of us in
healthcare have known for a long time
which is Healthcare is very wasteful
creates a lot of medical waste but it's
also inefficient and expensive so we
focus on medical devices that can be
reused and repurposed lumber which saves
hospitals money reduces waste but we've
also found it now reduces emissions so
the contributors to greenhouse gas
emissions and it helps to build supply
chain resilience I mean there's
shortages for medical devices now
because many of them contain microchips
uh if we get to a position where we have
to cancel procedures for patients then
this is a public health emergency and so
extending the lifespan of medical
devices is suddenly a very hot issue to
the larger public
now where are we at today so if you had
to sort of take me through the Journey
of the landscape today for medical
devices and you know maybe just some
high level numbers what what is the
situation that we're at today
yeah so when I started with the trade
Association right out of college it was
22 years ago this was a new industry and
we saved U.S hospitals about 20 million
dollars today we're saving U.S hospitals
over half a billion dollars but I think
the trajectory is going to get even more
rapid there is just such an enormous
amount of attention being placed on
supply chain vulnerabilities and
shortages for medical equipment costs
are out of control there's a nursing
shortage how are we going to reward
nurses with more pay if there isn't more
money
um and then the waste and the emissions
and so thinking more circularly or
holistically about the things we use in
healthcare rather than just employing
this culture of disposability is is
really important right now and so I
expect a trajectory to be even faster
and uh hospitals in Europe Canada the
United States and a number of other
places are going to demand more Holistic
Solutions like reprocessing and so I
think you know about two to three
billion dollars is in the forecast for
the next five to ten year Horizon
and what is your role in this little
space and pushing the space forward
so right now there are seven companies
that I represent that are in this space
that actually reprocessing medical
devices I run their trade Association so
we address the legal the regulatory or
the other syrup trade barrier issues
addressing the industry we now have
regulatory oversight by the usfda and
have since 2000 but now in Europe Canada
and Japan an increasing list of of
countries but having the regulator
oversee and certify that what we're
doing is safe and effective just like
any other medical equipment or a
pharmaceutical is really key for us in
legitimizing this business and
demonstrating to patients and clinicians
that this is the right thing to do
um and so the trade Association has been
very engaged in getting governments on
board with regulating reprocessing so
that we can prove that these products
are safe and effective
100 so can you give me a concrete
example of sort of the three processing
for somebody who's not coming from the
medical field or or you know Healthcare
in general show and tell but I know that
doesn't work out podcasts so for those
that are can actually see so this is a
laparoscope I'm holding up a device that
you know looks like a gut right well and
the distal tip is what's insertive this
is laparoscopic so meaning minimally
invasive and this device uses Harmonic
Technology or ultrasound technology to
sort of cauterize for lack of a better
word and uh seal tissue it's 450 dollars
for this particular maker model three to
four or two to three are typically used
in a medical procedure but as you can
see it has to be hooked up to a
generator and there's a microchip in
this thing and at 450 bucks and you use
three of these for a procedure and
because it has these rare materials you
can imagine hospitals don't want to be
throwing this away and so we reprocess
for the hospital under FDA regulation to
ensure that it's safe and effective and
the cost savings are about half but as
you can have per use meaning if you
reprocess it five times it's fifty
percent each use then buying it new but
it also reduces an enormous amount of
waste as you can imagine uh and it helps
build resilience there's a shortage for
these devices right now and so extending
the lifespan of products has been really
hot topic right now
but I mean it sounds I mean it kind of
trivial that we'll want to you know
reuse as many items as we can
or for many reasons you know time costs
you know mindset Etc and so I'm I'm
curious as to what are the different
challenges that are presented here that
make this a unique a unique you know
environment to be doing this in well
it's it's evident right now that there's
shortages for medical products that we
should be extending the lifespan or or
looking at things more holistically but
it has to talk to another in America in
particular we have a disposability type
of culture or take make waste linear
economy models where we take you know
materials from the Earth make things use
them and then just waste them and it's
not sustainable it's not sustainably
financially or or environmentally but
because in health care
we just a thought disposability is best
because then we'll never have an
infection control issue and we'll just
throw everything away well there's no
way there's just somewhere else and so
creating all of this stuff and then
incinerating it puts toxins in the
atmosphere which uh or or burning the
fuels to make these things which Elevate
greenhouse gas emissions which are
actually contributing to adverse health
effects and so in healthcare I actually
think we have a special responsibility
to be addressed in sustainability uh
because we take serious this oath of Do
no harm and disposability does no harm
to the patient in front of us but
incinerating all this waste is giving
kids asthma and cancer and creating a
global warming and these are things that
we in healthcare should be preventing
yep I like it so you're when you're
looking at specific device in the
specific industry and you're thinking
about okay there is an opportunity that
I understand here
um there's an opportunity to repurpose
or to change some mechanisms can you
share with me the process that you go
through so from the identification of
the opportunity to the validation of it
and then to actually the execution of
repurpose sure yeah so first of all you
know manufacturers have an enormous
incentive to sell more devices and so
they use the single-use label because if
you just throw away the scalpel at the
end of a procedure then you know you
have to come back and buy more
additionally regulatorily if you show up
at FDA and you want to sell a surgical
scalpel if you label it for single use
you don't have to do a cleaning
validation you don't have to write
cleaning instructions you don't have to
validate the cleaning instructions you
don't have to do a sterilization
validation so it's a lot cheaper and
easier to get through FDA by putting
single use on it and this is contributed
to this disposability culture my numbers
on the other hand look at these devices
and say how can we extend the light from
proof to the regulator that we can clean
it and sterilize it and it will still be
functional and so in order to sort of
meet that criteria there has to be
sufficient enough of volumes of the
medical device for us to make it
profitable they have to be sufficiently
expensive enough like this 450 dollar
scalpel and they have to be sufficiently
well built obviously to withstand
disassembly cleaning repair and
reassembly and that has landed us the
current product offerings are certain
three places surgical devices as I
mentioned like this laparoscopic scalpel
the cardiovascular catheterization lab
so devices that are actually thread into
the heart to uh do electrophysiology or
ablative procedures and then other
devices we just call nursing so blood
pressure cuffs pulse oximeter sensors
tourniquet cuffs
um air transfer mattresses things that a
lot of people assumed were reusable or
actually labeled as disposable or single
use and so we have to go back to prove
to FDA that our reprocessing processes
results of the device the cessation
effective at each turn
and so how is this sort of Team built
what what is how is this organization
how is the structured organizational you
know I'm trying to compare to how I
would imagine a startup a software
startup solving it it has uh how What's
Happening Here
yeah well you know medical technology
companies build great stuff and so we
rely a lot from our peers within the
larger med tech industry and those
Engineers but what we're doing is
reverse engineering right so we may not
saying company that made the product and
so we have to demonstrate to the
regulator that we understand how it
works and how many minutes the trigger
needs to be pulled to generate this type
of energy and so uh we hire a lot of
Engineers and so we're very Tech heavy
industry but we also have to hire
biomedical Engineers who are experts in
cleaning and sterilization and you know
the types of things that you would
anticipate the regulator and just you
know wants to see
right no no that makes a lot of sense so
going back to your own Journey then and
some of the things that you're
particularly excited about how did you
get into this how did this whole thing
how did I get into this
um law school or right out of uh
undergrad and there was a law firm
Washington DC where I got a school that
was looking for somebody to run this new
startup trade Association on a
day-to-day basis uh I knew I wanted to
go to law school these companies that
I'm representing now were very young at
the time so they let me go to law school
at night uh and you know here we are 22
years later I've been doing a legal and
Regulatory work for for two decades I
think what brought me personally to the
issue was the sustainability factor and
I've always been you know fancy myself
saw for somewhere of a green person but
I've learned a lot
friend of mine rabashi from Yale wrote a
book called The sustainability scorecard
and she does a much more eloquent job
than I could in explaining that you know
to be green doesn't have to be more
expensive you know being more holistic
or adopting sort of a circular economy
business model is good businesses it's
less intensive on resources it's less
intensive on on the environment it
requires less Fuel and so it's actually
a good business to run a green business
and I'm really proud to be an example of
that and I think what we're doing in the
reprocessing world the sort of circular
business model where we're recapturing
the things and putting them back into
production I think it's going to be the
future because medical products are so
expensive you know I see a future where
reprocessing and repair or servicing are
what the companies are going to sell not
disposable products that you throw away
and as an example you know right now in
the airline industry
um aircraft engine manufacturers GE and
Rolls-Royce they don't sell engine
they sell engine arcs and so the
alignment between the Airlines and the
aircraft engine manufacturers are are
more consistent meaning they both want a
more efficient Engine with more uptime
less downtime more interchangeable parts
and right now hospitals are not aligned
with medical device makers medical
device makers sell more and the hospital
loses more money versus the hospital you
know if they have to buy more than it
requires it rewards the medical device
manufacturer and I think that's the
wrong incentive I think there's still
immense profitability to be made in
healthcare without without the current
business model which is so wasteful and
I think adopting circular Solutions
likely processing will in the end do
better for the patient
certainly financially better for the
environment it's frankly also better for
their Healthcare practitioners as well
in their in their bid to do no harm
um are there other
Industries That You observe that are
going to go through similar
transformations to the one that ones
that you've mentioned now and and
specifically what your experience with
medical devices are we seeing the you
know some seeds coming out from
different Industries
well you know as I mentioned the airline
industry is one where they are we could
learn from them such as these aircraft
engine manufacturers I don't know
honestly my expertise is in med tech so
I'm very uh interested uh in what's
happening but I think the pain meant
so like the payment models or how we
sort of yeah place we post put so much
emphasis on volume
in order to get the discount and not on
value and I think the insurance
companies and the government are going
to start to rapidly start to reward
value-based Healthcare outcomes not
procedures or devices it's the wrong
incentive and it's what's making
American Healthcare the most expensive
in the world and interestingly also the
most environmentally toxic in the world
of if the if you took all Global Health
Care
and treated it as a country
it would be the fifth biggest emitter on
Earth
and that's Healthcare American Health
Care is twice as bad over eight percent
of Health Care emissions in the U.S or
just to be over eight percent of all the
missions in the US are coming from
Healthcare and I think that would
surprise people
that's pretty pretty unbelievable if you
had to outline your vision
for this industry you know moving
forward how do you define the vision of
this industry
yeah I think the future is in in
serviceization or in reprocessing and
remanufacturing instead of selling a
product we're going to sell you a
service and so I anticipate a future
where the big medical device companies
are going to work more closely with us
they develop wonderful technology but we
have amazing Logistics reverse
engineering and reprocessing skills that
they may not have I think our combined
forces can do things to really reduce
the cost of Health Care reduce emissions
and waste uh improve resilience uh and I
think all of these collectively are
going to be better for the American
Consumer in the American economy and
frankly most products Pharmaceuticals
are made here in America and so the rest
of the world is going to need what we
buy and if we're going to do anything
about global warming or try to meet
these Net Zero targets we need to offer
them Solutions where we can quantify
lower lower waste and lower emissions
and how and where are you from it you
know how optimistic are you that this is
the vision that we really are you know
running towards
uh I I I'm dead Set uh I'm in it we're
in the solution business here
um I know we've met 20 years experience
that we deliver these benefits and so I
know now that we're quantifying in
addition to the cost Savings in addition
to the waste production we're not
quantifying through life cycle analysis
we can quantify how much less carbon is
emitted with our reprocessing process
than in the original manufacturer and it
will be a game changer when when
Industries are forced to account for
their emissions associated with their
manufacturing model circular Business
Solutions like reprocessing are going to
come out ahead I've already seen the did
tip so how many years do you think it's
gonna take until we are turning the
tables and you know the the US
Healthcare System is no longer in this
in in a stage where we need to be having
this conversation and and I need to be
learning about these different things
that are happening that maybe I want to
get involved with
yeah well the transformation has already
begun
um CMS which pays for most uh Medicare
Medicaid in the United States is
released through its ahrq the agency for
healthcare quality research data for
hospitals and tips for hospitals on how
to begin to reduce their carbon
footprint because we've committed a Net
Zero by some so if we're going to get
there we actually have to identify
Solutions and so reprocessing is already
on that list but I think the move has
begun and it's going to rapidly Snowball
the more people are paying attention and
frankly the upper generation of
consumers and clinicians are much more
interested in sustainability and much
more interested in cost and so we're
looking at things also more holistically
rather than just ordering the procedure
or ordering there there were thoughtful
about you know can my patient afford to
have this done to take the time off work
and these are considerations that I
think are important when delivery
Healthcare that have often been
overlooked
100 what do you enjoy most
about what you do you have to look at
you know your journey either today or
higher level what is it that you really
enjoy most about what you're doing
uh given the increased attention
to the intersection of healthcare and
sustainability it's been a pleasure to
do interviews like this and to meet
people and policy makers who don't
necessarily think about these two issues
the way I do every day let alone even
know that our such a thing as this is
medical device reprocessing just to
introduce this business model the
solution that we offer I think a lot of
light bulbs go off and if we can
convince enough of these policy makers
or the people who are making the
decisions on how to reimburse Healthcare
I think that's going to make the most
Monumental change the other is meeting
with clinicians you know there's always
been some level of interest in research
and and what it is that we're doing but
now an enormous amount of academics
where the researchers or clinicians have
reached out to us to say let's do some
studies evaluating how much less
wasteful you know reprocessing would be
let's just do a study to evaluate how
many less you know tons of carbon we
commit if we reprocessed X Y and Z or
how much the us could save if we
reprocess more you know and all of those
those types of things have been very
interesting and it's been really uh it's
been fun in a in a challenge to meet
with a lot of these uh you know clinical
and research types but I've appreciated
it it's been fun
incredible and Dan thank you so much for
your time and for your uh thoughts and
explanations I really appreciate it best
of luck with the continued vision and
journey sounds incredible and and I look
forward to trying from the side
thank you very much
thank you very very much
[Music]